it does seem like the search for truth
which was one of the foundational
purposes of education really seems to
have gotten eroded or corroded or lost
where right now if you hear
college
administrator is talking a lot of it's
just about how to
retain
interest in enrollment in certain majors
and what people's professional prospects
are going to be afterwards
where a lot of liberal arts and schools
are being challenged and i think the the
most common major is economics and then
i know computer science now is shooting
up the charts because now it seems like
that's the purpose of education yeah
that's right uh i i think that the
universities are not just sick i think
that they're on hospice and they've
they've veered from their truth-seeking
mission and instead
uh really many professors in fact i
would argue depending on the field most
professors if something ends in studies
it's particularly worse these are
they're not true seeking uh
fields they're basically indoctrination
centers and that's how they look at the
classrooms so it you can think about it
like a catechism they ask certain
questions of students and students
respond in certain ways and they go into
the classroom not trying to find truth
but thinking that they already have the
truth and that's incredibly dangerous
not just for students but for the
democracy
[Music]
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to forward
modern day philosopher someone i've
admired from afar for quite some time
peter bogosian peter welcome
thank you andrew it's a pleasure to be
here thank you appreciate it so i'm just
going to speak for myself i was a young
angsty teen and so there was always like
an interest in philosophy but like a lot
of other people listening to this i
maybe dabbled in one philosophy course
in college and then turned around
i think it was like the first and last
philosophy course i took
so
how the heck does one actually become a
real life philosopher and i want you to
rewind back to you know when you were a
kid did you read
uh books that would lead you in that
direction so how does one become a real
life philosopher well anybody can be a
philosopher the trick is to be if you
want that path the trick is to be an
academic philosopher
i i've always been interested in
philosophy i've always been interested
in really intense things so
uh i think philosophy is the most
intense intellectual pursuit
uh like jiu-jitsu is the most for me
it's always been one of the most intense
physical pursuits and so
you wait wait
philosophy the jujitsu of intellectual
disciplines it's just been branded
poorly peter
that's exactly what it is that's exactly
what it is yeah and that's what socrates
used to do he used to do a kind of
intellectual or
almost a cognitive jujitsu where he
would basically ask people if they
agreed with themselves
yes he'd use the method on them and then
say hey like uh pinned you
submit
that's right yeah that's actually what
and that that's what i think we've lost
that's what i'm writing a book in fact
just before our conversation i'm writing
a children's book about the young
socrates and he travels a mythical greek
countryside
and he
has conversations with all different
sorts of people because
anybody can access the truth regardless
of their immutable characteristics so
truth is just
not linked to to who we are as people
this sounds like it should be a netflix
series my friend freaking young socrates
and he shows up in the new village
yeah faker
yes his superpower is reason and he has
conversations across all these divides
with different creatures and it's yeah
it's it's fun it's fun to write so but i
guess any anybody can be a philosopher
it just means thinking more deeply and
usually systematically about things love
it loving wisdom so you grew up in
massachusetts and when did you imagine
that you might even study philosophy oh
boy uh well i i realized that it was
not a very practical thing to do
that's what i'm thinking at man because
like we all know it's not very practical
so i'm trying to figure out like you
know like how the heck you
you wound up someplace that yeah that
none of the rest of us did well i
minored in it in uh i minored in it in
as an undergraduate i majored in
psychology but i didn't really like psy
i like psychology but it just it just
i don't know there was some something
about it that seemed
i don't want to say say fake and that's
right now we have a replication crisis
where we can't reproduce studies in
psychology but
it just philosophy really hit me and
really answering life's deep questions
like what does it mean to live a good
life and what kind of death should you
have and what's the nature of friendship
and what are the boundaries can you be
unjust towards yourself and what is
justice and what is truth and how do we
be fair to people and i think there was
always a
i've always had a bs detector it hasn't
been very good but i've honed it over
the years that's one thing philosophy if
done right will do it'll hone your bs
detector sometimes wow we need a whole
lot more philosophy than in american
life my friend
people need bs detectors at higher
levels this is what to me is really
interesting and i know it's
counterintuitive but
the more one studies philosophy the
worse off one's epistemic situation
could be
explain that so epistemology is like how
you know so um and the believing brain
my friend michael shermer
has a a part about i i personally think
this is the greatest insight in all of
critical thinking so why do smart people
believe weird things smart people
believe weird things because they're
better at rationalizing to a conclusion
in other words they're better at coming
up with with
bad reasons to believe or good reasons
depending how you look at it to believe
their conclusions
one of the things philosophy does is
it teaches people how to come up with
good reasons for things even if the
things that they're coming up with are
false
so it's possible and i've actually seen
this repeatedly that people who who are
very adept at philosophy and they're
adept at making arguments uh they get
caught in these intellectual rabbit
holes where they
uh become very good at coming up with
reasons to believe things that are are
morally fashionable so you admired in
philosophy and then did you end up uh
getting a graduate degree in it i think
you did right because you're you must
have to be able to teach it
yeah i i got a um i got a master's
degree in philosophy from fordham got a
doctorate in education from psu in
portland state and i did my dissertation
on
in prisons and i found questions
throughout the history of western
philosophy and i taught inmates how to
desist from crime
using these questions so that they can
uh think morally so how to reason
through moral issues with the with the
goal of um desisting from crime so who
was the first philosopher that had a
major impact on you it must have been uh
relatively early on like in your teenage
years yes it was relatively early on it
was uh socrates in specific specifically
it was both
the the republic and the apology the
apology just blew my mind i mean it
totally changed my whole world i read
that and i was just forever forever
intellectually changed i mean here's a
guy socrates who's
you know charged with impiety and you
know not believing in the gods he gives
this incredible defense he's found
guilty they let him say a few words and
what does he say he asks for a reward
right he asks he asks i mean it's just
it's such a it's such a mind-blowing
thing and then it just talks about the
death of socrates and when socrates died
there was something
that
indelibly marked centuries of our
intellectual exploration that also died
i just had an interview and somebody
asked me what do you what do you think
the most important human invention ever
was and i said the socratic method
um but but i would argue it's it's not
just a human adventure invention any
space-faring
civilization would have to have some
version of the socratic method if not
actually the socratic method you know
it's kind of like falsification but in
the moral in the moral sphere you know
how do we fall how do we move uh ideas
forward test them
have some kind of mechanism it's
basically what science is but for
moral and other questions
[Music]
you know we all get down in the dump
sometime no time more so than now i mean
the honest truth is that a lot of people
are struggling right now you'd be kind
of weird if you weren't struggling but
you have to do something about it you
have to take action
and one of the absolute best ways to
take action is actually to talk to
someone now you have friends yes you
have family members yes but they are not
really cut out to be your sounding board
for a lot of this stuff but you know who
is a licensed therapist through better
help i think of this as uber for mental
health
and if you do this you're going to be so
glad because it's a professional
therapist who's on call for you whenever
you need them you can ping them day or
night you can start communicating with
someone in under 48 hours so if this
sounds like it would be good for you and
it really would be good for just about
all of us i kid you not
go to betterhelp.com as a listener to
this podcast you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
yang over one million people have taken
charge of their mental health you should
too again that's
betterhelphelp.comyang i am pumped to
promote better help because it will
actually help just about every single
person
[Music]
i remember
being exposed to various philosophers uh
as an undergraduate not to the depth
that that you have
uh and i do remember certain ideas each
philosopher seems to have embedded in
our collective culture right
one of the the things that i i know
right now and we'll get to
what's happened with you and academia
um where it does seem like the search
for truth which was one of the
foundational
purposes of education really seems to
have gotten eroded or corroded or lost
where right now if you hear
college
administrators talking a lot of it's
just about how to
retain
interest in enrollment in certain majors
and what people's professional prospects
are going to be afterwards
where a lot of liberal arts and schools
are being challenged and i think the the
most common major is economics
and then i i know computer science now
is shooting up the charts because now it
seems like that's the purpose of
education yeah that's right uh i i think
that the universities are not just sick
i think that they're on hospice and
they've
they've veered from their truth-seeking
mission and instead
uh really many professors in fact i
would argue depending on the field most
professors if something ends in studies
it's particularly worse these are
they're not true seeking uh
fields they're basically indoctrination
centers and that's how they look at the
classrooms so it you can think about it
like a catechism they ask certain
questions of students and students
respond in certain ways and they go into
the classroom not trying to find truth
but thinking that they already have the
truth and that's incredibly dangerous
not just for students but for the
democracy my run-up against a lot of
this was
in college and then i went to law school
which is also supposed to be kind of a
truth-seeking profession which is
a little bit of bunk
shall we say like you're reading old
case law
that's the way i was trained i was
trained uh
as a lawyer i was a lawyer for
a brief time i did pass the bar and all
that jazz um but i think that legal
studies touches philosophy
at least peripherally because that there
is at least a purported
search for truth when you're reading
case law and judicial reasoning
i'm not sure if people still believe
that now in this day and age where
everything's gotten politicized but the
way i was taught was that these judges
were accessing
some kind of truth
that was beyond their their own
uh impulses or decision that they were
supposed to be impartial and reason
their way to a
better
judgment
uh and i know a lot of them even would
refer to philosophers at various points
in their rulings yeah and you didn't you
must not have enjoyed that process or
liked the profession because you left
well there were certain aspects of
studying it that i didn't mind at all um
you know i think the problem with law
school is that you become a lawyer after
really
like the study itself it's like you know
kind of interesting uh and what not um
but then the the profession of it um is
quite different i likened it to a pie
eating contest where if you win they
give you more pie um that didn't seem
like a great way
to spend
one's waking hours and so i left to
become an entrepreneur
so in your case you were getting your
phd
at pacific state you were teaching these
inmates uh and it must have been
somewhat daunting for you to think hey
i'm going to make a living in this field
because there is obviously a joke about
about
unemployed or uh or unemployable
philosophers so in your case you must
have known that if you were going to do
it academia was going to be the path
yeah i never really worried about making
a living because i i knew
to speak very
bluntly i hope this doesn't doesn't
sound self-aggrandizing but
i knew two things about myself one i
know that i have a capacity to work that
is unparalleled i work constantly from
the moment i wake up
i work at every aspect of life so i knew
that that um i
that increased my odds of success you
know i come from you know my
grandparents of immigrants and and that
mentality oh where from
my my um
dad's parents are from armenia and they
escaped the genocide and then my mom's
parents are from uh greece and italy got
it it's on the child of immigrants so i
i know exactly what you're saying yeah
so no so i had that that um work ethic
and i have that but you know my my dad
would tell me this story when his dad
escaped from uh the
genocide in turkey
he would be he was on a coal ship
and he actually died of lung cancer
eventually but when he would uh when he
was on it they just need him and when
the other guys were on i won't mention
where they're from they needed three of
them and so this this thing like you
know you're armenian you work hard and
and to succeed that's what you need to
do that's the other thing we've lost now
we blame it on systems uh so any
disparity and outcome has to be due to a
system as opposed to a value that an
individual or a culture possesses i mean
we could talk about that if you want so
yeah i mean
that's an interesting one for sure peter
because
i'm someone who loves loves loves
entrepreneurs and builders and
uh people who are making positive things
happen and i also think that the systems
are kind of
messed up
like both can be true in my mind um but
i i would agree with you that people
have taken something of an either or
stance where if someone is failing it's
purely systemic and not necessarily born
of their uh individual actions or
inactions and here's the butt and we
have a huge butt here that i i'm certain
that we both agree on
and the but for that is it's incumbent
upon the society to have a quality of
opportunity so you can never mitigate
for
you know a parent who's abusive or you
know if you look at the incarceration
rates kids have incarcerated one parent
incarcerated they're seven times more
likely to be incarcerated themselves so
so the goal should be
we want to create systems that are fair
by equality of opportunity but i think
that we agree profoundly on
what it means to
that nobody should be
disadvantaged because of their race or
because of an exogenous characteristic
or because they're from some zip code
but there are just fiscal and financial
realities that sit in but i think it's
incumbent upon us to think about the
problem in terms of equality of
opportunity and and that's the way how
do we make our institutions more just
how do we give every kid a public
education the first rate good food you
know tasty food not those shitty little
pizzas in the cans uh
when they when they go into their
classrooms are you a parent yourself
peter
i am i have two two kids
oh how old my son is uh let's see my son
is 20. wow my my daughter is uh my
daughter's adopted from china um we got
her two and a half and she's she's 15
now she's just learning to drive and
it's very interesting
i i gotta uh as portland is really
becoming quite a [ __ ] and somebody
who i think pretty pretty sure they
stole the car and they smashed into my
parked car so i went to get a a
a rental car it's in the shop
and they only had one car left because
of covid and i got this this crazy
freaking mustang like you open the door
and it has like you know the horse on
the ground and nice
yeah my daughter's learning to drive and
she just loves it's been such a i just
would never even sit in this car and it
has it's like the opposite of a tesla
it's loud and it's jerky
um
and that's what she's learning and i
like it well she loves driving around it
and she loves hanging out well she loves
watching me drive around in it
[Music]
all right one thing you can do that's
going to make you feel better about
yourself is treat your body right there
are different ways to do that you can
sleep you can exercise and you can eat
better you can ingest actual nutrients
and if you are like me you want to do
the right thing but it's not always easy
to track down that kale that salad that
thing you know you should eat so you
know how you can actually solve this
problem and make yourself healthier on
the regular athletic greens you just
take one scoop you combine it with water
and it contains 75 vitamins minerals
when you drink it you know you're doing
something good for your body you know
what i mean you know when you take
something and it's like okay i just did
something really really good for myself
that is athletic greens to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free
one year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens
athleticgreens.com yang today again
simply visit athleticgreens.com
yang to take control of your health and
give ag-1 a try you will be glad you did
ag-1 will make you feel like you are
treating your body right and it is so
easy just take that
mix you put it in water you drink it and
you just are super charged for the day
[Music]
so you had um
this phd and then did you transition
directly into academia and you ended up
teaching at the
uh same school that you got your
doctorate is that right well i i taught
oh my gosh i taught at so many
universities i taught i you know i
i taught at loyola in new orleans i
taught university of phoenix i used to
fly around the country for them i taught
i mean i've taught it you you name it
i've taught i mean i've just taught so
many places uh and then i i had a was
offered a position at portland state
and i took that position it was it was a
non-tenure track
uh and it was a head it was a heavy
course load you know i i taught a lot of
students and those were big classes you
know 120 people per class we had big
classes and i taught three classes a
term but even in spite of that so this
is interesting so i had been teaching
before that
in crazy like i would literally wake up
i don't know i've never told anybody
this so if this is uninteresting let me
know but i would wake up
and i would i would teach morning
classes at like university of portland
or linfield what have you every day
then i would go to
teach afternoon classes and then i would
teach night classes like at devry
or
university of phoenix or any of these
places online and i would literally
teach so many students and then i'd get
off at 10
and i'd go to the gym and i'd come home
and i would immediately begin writing
until i passed out i would pass out
at my computer and i would wake up often
to the alarm and then i would just do
the whole thing again and i think you
know to succeed
not well in philosophy in general
but i think that's that's the kind of
thing and i'm not saying that's a good
life or i advocated for any anybody in
particular but i think one thing that's
at issue is
often
which relates i'm saying this because it
relates to my earlier comment
often people become resentful
be at the system because they don't they
feel that they should be more successful
than they are but one of the things that
they don't realize is how hard you have
to work to be successful i mean look at
yourself i mean holy [ __ ] look what
you've done
and that's the other thing
you know the people who are successful
this is another lesson you learned from
jiu jitsu uh that people who are
successful once they're knocked down or
they lose a race they just get up and
they keep going and they use that as a
learning experience and that's a value
that we need to teach people not you
know the system is against you or you
didn't succeed so you might as well quit
no you just have to have that grit that
determination to keep going and do doing
stuff you love you know well in my
circles we call it the internal locus of
control versus the external which is
like if something goes wrong is it like
oh did i screw up or i go were the
chips stacked against me
uh in some way and you're right that
grit is the number one quality that
determines whether a child is going to
be successful over time are we teaching
our kids enough grit i can say for
myself personally that my kids seem very
very
soft relative
to the way i grew up uh which you know i
think part of that is inevitable if
you're
um
spending you know frankly more
generations in this country where my
parents didn't know what the heck was
going on so
my brother and i just kind of
tried to figure things out and we're
left to our own devices an awful lot
um so you t taught all over the place
and then we're offering this non-tenure
track position at portland state where
it seems like you were a workhorse and
taught a lot of uh students i have the
sense that you have a fairly
long-standing relationship with this
institution is that right how many years
uh have uh
been there very long very very
long-standing relationship with the
institution and i took the position it
took i originally got paid fifty
thousand dollars but remember i was
teaching literally thousands and
thousands of students so to go from what
i was doing
to teaching i don't know let's see 120
and 80 and 60 or 80 and 80 or something
to go to from teaching a crazy number of
students and i had great health care too
at that point were you a parent and
you'd settle down where you're like oh
wow like you know this might be stable
yeah i was i was a parent uh i you know
i had
my son and we hadn't adopted our
daughter yet so yeah does that mean
you've been in portland
for decades is that accurate yeah been i
think 1999 i think we came here now it's
decades brother 22 years boy man i mean
i cannot believe the state of the city i
i just am i'm the just just uh two days
ago
anarchists or and
cetera destroyed area of the downtown
that cost 550 000
uh of of my money of the taxpayer of the
citizens money and there's just no end
in sight the mayor is the mayor is a
public disgrace to be blunt with you uh
so i feel like portland has seen a boom
and then now i know it is kind of the
site to some of these
uh protests and conflicts to a higher
degree than just about any other
community in the country but you must
have seen it also developed tremendously
because i feel like it's had a boom over
the last number of years is that right
yeah i've seen the city develop and then
i've seen it
fall in a year and a half to substance
use disorders where people aren't
getting the services they need
to to homelessness oh and the gun deaths
the violence you know the the mayor and
the city council got rid of the gun
reduction task force team because they
said it was racist
and the consequence of that was the um
we we now have have more young young
dead black males and now they they've
put in the gun reduction task force but
it may be too late
so this is a very very small thing but i
was in san francisco a week and a half
ago and i went into a walgreens to pick
up a toiletry and then
someone robbed the walgreens while i was
there and
the staff kind of looked up
half-heartedly
as he ran out with like a bag full of
stuff and it was it just i was looking
around at everyone being like so this is
happening now and then right uh and then
someone i was with just shrugged and
said san francisco you know like that
that was a matter of course and then i
later heard that they might have closed
a number of walgreens into school
because because there was a whole string
of uh robberies that apparently had
become
um not just one-offs but there was like
a ring right and the d.a i think chase
bourdain is his name the d.a doesn't
prosecute those crimes uh and i'm
supposed to have a sit down with the d.a
of portland who's we have a mutual
friend and i'm really looking forward to
that i've been smashing him on slamming
on him on twitter for a year
and so
you know that's another thing like
what you know is is it like you know
okay so one one take the d.a here and i
hate to speak for him because i haven't
met him yet but you know his his
uh philosophy
is to
uh you know punish murders and
the harshest most strict crimes it's
kind of the opposite of the broken
windows theory which we know the
evidence is overwhelming for decades now
uh especially from new york and out
which that works and when you what what
is the consequence of not prosecuting
those smaller crimes i've also heard
from
police i do jiu jitsu with they were
telling me that people know that cops no
longer come out so when my car was
smashed by someone who stole a car
the actual the woman who lives with us
uh didn't drive didn't call the police
because the police don't come out for
that anymore it takes him an hour and a
half to come out for a kidnapping in
progress but people know this and then
they come to portland knowing this
but it just it's the astonishing thing
is it doesn't seem to to bother the
mayor very much well i i would imagine
then people are voting with their feet
because that's what a lot of people try
to do in this situation where folks look
up and say you know what i'm a parent
i've got a family maybe i should uh head
towards uh toward the suburbs someplace
is that yep
yep that's 100 accurate i know so many
friends uh so many friends of mine in
the middle class who are doing that the
problem though besides the fact that it
leaves the city to be an even bigger
dump because the tax revenue
degrades is that people in lower
socioeconomic stratas can't leave
because they don't have the money to
leave so then they're stuck with the
violence and the gangs and the drugs and
the filth and the trash and the general
incivility and divisiveness so it really
screws over people poor people
i i mean i don't
know some of what's going on on the
ground aside from what you see on
twitter occasionally which i know you've
been very prominent on twitter
you and i first became acquainted
during my presidential
and you first came to i think national
attention
when you posted some academic papers
that had patently ridiculous subjects um
that somehow passed muster and then were
published in various low-level academic
journals
uh and some of these were very humorous
i thought they were very funny i'm gonna
i'm gonna stop you not low level
academic journals top journals in there
in their field with things related to
studies like gender studies the journals
in the field so describe like the run-up
to that because that wasn't the first
thing you did i mean there were
it sounds like a number of years when
you were being exposed to changes in
your environment and you were addressing
them in certain ways
and then that was a relatively dramatic
recourse right so so how how did the
environment change over time and how
many years
uh were you witnessing uh before you
decided to to do that i i realized that
maybe in 2011 2012 but i didn't realize
that the the system itself was creating
a kind of
fragility and and
intellectual and emotional uh
brittleness
and sooner soon it it dawned on me that
this
madness was coming from certain bodies
of literature
and i would follow a
twitter feed called new real peer review
where they would post the abstracts and
then some of the analyses of articles
that were just totally insane that were
being published and remember seven
papers in seven years is tenure so
people were credentialing themselves and
getting tenure
because they would have just totally
deranged ideas and so we published a
buddy i told my buddy that you know
following in the the trails of alan
sokol
who was a new york who it still is um
nyu professor of mathematics and physics
where he wrote a bogus paper in the late
90s for the premier post-modern journal
and i said well we should do that and so
we published this piece the conceptual
penis as a social construct and you can
find it just put in the link in the
youtube channel i thought it was
hilarious uh but we did it to
demonstrate that there are problems in
certain fields and if you forward
certain conclusions those will
those papers are more likely to get
accepted and that public policies are
being formed on that so we caught
mad grief for that people went nuts and
a lot of those criticisms were justified
you know the journal wasn't high enough
factor it was too new or whatever but
basically they said if you wanted to
prove
what you think you proved you have to do
a b c d e so i turned to my buddy and i
said this is awesome man they've given
us a road map let's do it and we we
published 20 papers
and then the new york i mean the wall
street journal busted us
once we got our seventh publication and
these papers were insane i mean one of
them even won an award
[Music]
here the podcast we're always talking
about better ways to solve problems you
know what i mean solutions it's a
problem that all of us have and there's
actually a better way to get clean after
you go to the bathroom now if you're
like me you like to take things from
other countries other countries have
adopted bidets at very high levels
because they're better for the
environment they're more effective
there's less waste it actually works and
now you can do the same thing here at
home with tushy it's a bidet that just
attaches to your toilet
less waste better for the environment
more effective you'll feel like you're
treating yourself right
every single day is that not fun
you can also gift it for someone else
you can give the gift of a clean bum to
yourself your loved ones this holiday
season and get 10 off plus free shipping
right now at
hellotushy.com yang i love this product
because it actually is better for the
earth better for you better for everyone
you can tag
at hellotushy on social media they will
celebrate you they really are very
lovely on online that's
hellotushi.comyang for 10 off and free
shipping you'll be glad your family
members will be glad who knows maybe
your loved one will be glad too much
information hello tushy
[Music]
did you publish these under a pseudonym
or were they as yourselves or
like how were they submitted yeah that
was the fatal flaw we only had one real
person uh and it was a buddy of mine
richard baldwin who's uh is a
70 something year old guy he's a former
professional bodybuilder that's why a
lot of our papers are about bodybuilding
so he let us use his name so we used his
name
but we made up the other names that's
how we got busted by the way one of the
things we did was um we we gave this
person
uh a um
we gave this person a a fake a fake name
and a fake degree and we said that she
had a phd in feminist studies
and uh somebody called around and fought
i mean the paper was just so and utterly
insane that uh that
journalists saw what the
uh journal editors did not see and
that's what happens when you live in
these tight-knit knit these ecosystems
is you just you just don't see how crazy
it is because every that's also what
happens when you call out ins call
intellectual diversity out of a system
when people have the same ideological
underpinnings part of the problem is
that
they just think it's normal to believe
things that are just totally untethered
to reality one of the great lessons i
learned running for president peter was
just how
institutionalized
our country is where
you can take a look at any field
certainly politics definitely media i'll
throw technology in there for fun but
the the things that you
traffic in and accept in those
environments and the things by the way
that you completely ignore
uh are are really born of a certain kind
of group think
uh and when you get in there you realize
just how deep it is
uh right and and so some of the the
conclusions you can come to
uh would only make sense to the people
who are in that domain and outside of
that domain you'd be like this doesn't
make any sense like well you know why
the heck are you uh doing this or
ignoring that i mean
one of the great frustrations i had
running for president was i was talking
about the automation of millions of
manufacturing jobs news organizations
would act like i was speaking another
language and then there was part of me
that was like
i just like make up a number you know i
mean it was four million but if i was
thinking to myself like would it make a
difference to you if it was like seven
million eight million like is there a
point at which it matters
[Laughter]
the answer is that there was no
threshold at which it would matter
that that and and this is one of the
reasons why i'm now
very convinced of
very negative outcomes um for our
country because like the institutions
that theoretically would stand up and
say hey turns out we did really
decimate like entire ways of life or
communities or want that there's no
acknowledgement no interest in
acknowledging it because there's no
institutional incentive to acknowledge
it ah
yeah that's right that's why i think
there's a crisis of i don't think i know
i've been tweeting about this and
talking about this for years there's a
crisis of legitimacy in our institutions
yes that crisis is is born of a number
of factors that's also why we need new
institutions so i'll say it here for the
first time ever uh
one i'm going to be part of a new
institution the university of austin in
texas
and it's has a
an amazing board neil ferguson is on
that heather hing barry weiss and others
um and so we need to build
it's not enough that we criticize or
claim there's a crisis of legitimacy in
our institutions and people have lost
trust and confidence in them we have to
build something new and so
i that's one of the things that one of
the mine i'm playing a a very small role
but i'm a founding faculty member in
that but i think that that's
congratulations peter that's super
exciting
thanks i appreciate that it's it's
certainly not a full-time gig but it's
something that i'm very passionate about
and it's based on free inquiry and the
open exchange of ideas and actually
debating people uh and we're going to
look at some
very difficult questions that that are
taboo and current universities
so i'm i'm i'm pretty excited about that
well i couldn't agree more peter this is
one of the things that motivates me
is that you have these failing
institutions that are losing legitimacy
and people are losing trust and they're
noticing and there are certain people
who throw stones at these institutions
saying they're
uh they're messed up and immoral though
the way they frame it in my mind is is
not precisely the way i'd approach it
like that they tend to frame it in terms
of identity where they say look that
like this yeah like this institution
is uh is excluding certain people which
it generally is um
but that that's
not to me actually like the the main
failing
like like there are other deeper
failings and problems
um
and
with that as your backdrop you do need
to try and build better versions correct
yeah and that's what i've that's one of
the things that i've always respected
and appreciated about you what you've
done is you've you've generally listened
to the other side and you have a
a
a remarkable ability to put your finger
on problems that are
uh small problems now that are um are
festering or germinating and about to be
larger problems and then address those
in some constructive way i mean that is
a unique gift i think we've seen the
decent what the internet has done with
the decentralization of technologies we
now see it in the university system but
we've seen it in every you know every
uh media we've seen it in the record
industry uh it's hitting the
universities now and it's hitting them
hard and you know i'm curious if i may
ask you a question so what what are you
thinking about with your new party in
terms of
uh k-12 institutions of higher education
have you worked out some of those ideas
yet we haven't really planted a flag
where our education is concerned in part
because if you're going to be this
unifying centrist party
you want to stick to broad principles
but i will say that
from my presidential campaign
uh to me right now schools are among the
institutions that are failing our kids
the most and that we should be most
deeply concerned about
and that two-thirds of our kids ability
to learn is determined outside of the
school
so in many ways we're actually holding
our teachers to impossible standards
saying make it work make it work and by
the way this kid's totally stressed out
and malnourished and like not in any
shape to learn and you can only control
about 35 of his performance or her
performance
and so
one of the things we should do is be
investing very significantly in the
other two thirds of their performance
which is try and get them into a
position or a home really where they're
actually able to learn and they're not
going to get abused and that there's
someone who'll actually
uh read words to them when they're very
young and like like all of these other
steps um so that's something that i
think
forward's going to be
uh pushing in part because uh right now
with with the failures inside of school
and there are a lot of ideas i have for
you know how you try and improve what's
going on in a classroom we can i think
make more rapid progress on some of the
things that are going on outside because
you don't have to go through legacy
institutions to your point about the
need to build new ones
yeah i'd be i'd be really interested
when you
um
i'd be really interested i might even be
be interested if you're interested in
having me i'd be interested in kind of
helping you formulate or think through
some of those ideas about
what kind of educational institutions we
want what is what should their
relationship be to serving the
democratic democratic interests or that
i don't mean the party the lower case d
democratic i i had it
yeah uh so yeah
so so yeah so i'd be interested in
helping you kind of think through or
formulate those ideas like
not only pedagogically if you look at
the stats the number of people being
homeschooled and not because of the
pandemic has gone up tremendously and
the number of conservatives who don't
trust the k-12 system has also
dramatically risen
and and we just can't have a society
that's just not healthy for democracy
it's deeply it's deeply unhealthy i
think the wrong framing is reinvigorate
i think the right the right framing is
reinstall trust in our educational
institutions well i love and i want to
hear more about what you're doing at the
university of austin um but let's lead
people to why the heck you're not at
what uh you know the institution you
taught at for
um for years and decades so what year
did you
publish these
uh farcical articles
that that ended up kind of demonstrating
the the uh
the let's say the lack of rigor in some
of these um
these publications 2018 yeah three years
ago and i imagine there was a firestorm
uh that came down on you right right
there after they went utterly insane
they
genuinely went crazy they went they they
just had a
yeah so so instead of saying oh geez
maybe there's a problem here or or maybe
we should
be more rigorous or thoughtful or maybe
the peer review system needs to be
we need to take a look more carefully at
this no it was you know i'm some type of
right-wing maniac
or um
you know
i'm a bad person because i didn't get
human subjects peer review or
i mean whatever any anything but an
honest examination of what the problem
actually was
which is that certain fields are
motivated by ideology they're not
truth-seeking and they're uh
these are journals that are set up where
people are discharging their moral
impulses at them
you know uh we call this a brett wine
center it's called ideal laundry it goes
in as an uh as a an idea a bunch of
people make an academic journal and it
comes out on the other end as knowledge
and then they point to this
and they say well how do you know
something well here it is the gold
standard peer review it's the gold
standard and then we formulate public
policy on that and the problem is that
we've now taught so many people this
we've taught a whole generation of
people this they take these these ideas
these deranged ideas with them and then
they go to the um
they they go to become administrators
they become supervisors they become
leaders some of them become journalists
peter but continue
no the journalists and that's also
lending itself to legitimacy crisis so
we did that in 2018
and the firestorm that it caused was
crazy but that's what happens when the
moral mind overrides the rational mind
right that's what happens when you look
at the institution as a place to
you know give people their view give
people this is the view you should hold
of reality and these are the things that
are most important and and the the the
interesting thing is i share many of
those views you know yeah i know what
you mean i mean i share a lot of goals
with a lot of people but you know uh
with certain politics
um but that that doesn't seem paramount
uh you know in the scheme of things
relative to some other what i consider
relatively minor trivial
differences you know it's like if you
have a vision for the world that
includes trying to help a lot of people
that are struggling i mean i i feel like
that yeah you know that's the important
thing
[Music]
it seems like you've had a very very
difficult several years like what are
some of the experiences that you went
through before you eventually very
recently said look enough is enough you
know like i'm like this is not not going
to be
my professional home anymore i knew that
every instance i stayed there i
compromised my integrity and and i think
i i think was megan kelly i said this
too so you know she said was there one
thing that caused you to leave because
at that point everybody you know my
students would come and say you just
can't leave please don't leave we have
nobody to talk to and so i i did feel an
obligation
to stay there and i also knew that
if i stayed there
you know i could bring in people to
speak and i could kind of show that many
of the
orthodoxies the things that people
believe they just they're just not true
but i i went in i couldn't
get him a meeting with the president of
the university i emailed him for a
five-minute meeting and i repeatedly and
i kept being told he was too busy too
busy for five minutes so i managed to
get a very brief meeting with the dean
and i i said to the to the then dean
portland state university made this is a
2020s list of the
um
worst schools for free speech
and the dean said to me
it's a good thing to be on those lists
and it just blew my mind like
you mean to tell me even then i was
harboring under the idea that okay you
know maybe this this isn't necessarily a
feature it's probably still a bug but no
you mean this is by design
by design you want to take away from
people's freedom of speech and you want
everyone to walk on eggshells and you
want
you know you don't want the students to
ask questions things that challenge the
the dominant moral orthodoxy you mean
that's by design i didn't say that to
him but
but it was in that moment that i'm like
okay i gotta leave the only question is
when after you publicly resigned um you
probably got some
love and warmth and admiration and some
people saying good riddance finally you
know like uh uh that
um this right-wing maniac i think you as
you heard yourself described uh is is is
leaving campus
um
well you know what what has the reaction
been it's been maybe four or five weeks
now something like that yeah it's been
over with i've i've been stunned andrew
by the reaction i've been shocked uh the
97 98 positive uh one percent negative
and one percent incoherent you know i
mean it's been overwhelmingly supportive
and positive like shockingly so
and the
so that's that's something else that's
that's been of interest to me so the
right wing had a feeding frenzy on this
story and so this is partially how the
game is played
so
i put out a series of tweets
here's a problem i'd like to talk about
so the president of portland state
university said that racial justice is
the highest priority of the institution
fact check that you can put a link to it
and
i i'd like to have a conversation with
people on the left not a debate i'll
even you know it's no gotcha i'll even
tell you the question beforehand should
racial justice be the highest priority
of a public institution
nobody would have that conversation with
me
cnn nbc msnbc opb which is the oregon
public broadcasting npr
the oregonian nobody nobody wanted
nobody on the left would talk to me so
here's how the game is played so
something will happen
the right will have a feeding frenzy you
go on right-wing shows you you you
express interest you'll even call on the
phone or you'll send emails or you make
it public to your twitter uh please i'd
like to have this conversation with you
nobody on the left will have a
conversation with you i shouldn't say no
when i take that back one person uh i've
had conversations with him his name is
david pakman he's the only person on the
left who'd speak to me david david's
dave is a good guy yeah he'll he'll
actually have a conversation with you
which is rather remarkable and then what
happens is so many people on the left
will say
uh look he only goes on this proves that
he's some kind of right wing lunatic he
only goes on right-wing shows so that
the whole game is rigged against you you
know i had a similar experience recently
where
i went on tucker carlson's show
and i have not been on any msnbc shows
and let's just say it was not because i
was turning on turning down invitations
right
you know
it is there is like a strange dynamic
where where
um you
like certain
organizations are more willing to have
you on than certain others almost feel
like they're protecting their audience
from people who might right and end up
causing them to question some of what
they're seeing or hearing right and
here's here's the problem so these echo
systems that they've created for
themselves
every time you go on tucker or i go on
tucker
again it's not only that they'll point
to you and say look
we knew we knew it yang was was really
right wing all along he's harboring the
sentiments that's just terrible for our
democracy that causes schisms but but
huge thing every time you point that out
to somebody
you get this what about ism
you know people say well well what about
the lunatics who uh uh went through the
capital or what about those other
lunatics who went who think that there's
a organization in the basement of a
pizza parlor okay well what about them i
mean i'm not talking about them i'm
talking about the media's ecosystems
that we've created and right now it is
endemic on the left they simply will not
speak to other people on the other side
of the issue and they just they just
won't even if you tell them what the
question is going to be they won't speak
to you nobody will talk about it you
know you get what a baptism you get
slandered but i do think that this
problem the right has yes the right has
many problems well yeah i know
it's one reason peter why i think we
need more than two parties because if
you have this exactly this duopoly and
then this schism and then this what
about ism it's like well i can just
point to the
uh the crazies on that side and you know
like whatever's going on over here is uh
nowhere close to that level um and and
people unfortunately will just lump
together tens of millions of americans
with with the most extreme people
um in that in that
camp so you know
it's breaking us well you're right it is
breaking us and the other part of that
is
the maniacs who invaded the capital or
the people the q anon people
these people do not control our academic
institutions they do not have tenure
they do not have jobs for life and
i don't see the prospect of intellectual
diversity at any time soon we need the
best arguments to be presented to our
students so let me just throw out
something else i um
was very involved in the new atheist
movement for a long time
and
uh that was a fascinating experience and
i learned a tremendous amount
from that i was teaching a class in
atheism uh so so i would would you know
teach them the arguments of these
existence of god but the problem is i
don't believe those arguments so i would
go out of my way to have somebody come
in i had phil fisher from veggietales i
had
the guy who's the lead christian
apologist for the largest corey miller's
name christian organization on college
campuses in the country uh rocio
christie he came in spoke to my we
actually went on tour together um but
somebody wrote phil smith who's a
conservative christian who teaches at a
conservative christian school here wrote
a lovely letter to the oregonian you
know peter bogosian had me in his
classes he was very respectful and i
tell people look
give him your best argument man you
believe it
and i don't say a thing i don't ask a
question it's the same format it's you
deliver a lecture and then you have an
hour q a
and
our kids need that they need people who
believe and they need to hear the best
arguments and
possible they need to learn how to treat
people with civility and respect while
being merciless on their ideas and then
they can make their own decisions but
that's not the institution we have we
don't have that these are not true
seeking ins
these are not places where people go to
search and to seek there are places that
people who believe they have answers go
to impart those answers aren't people
and that is a grotesque disservice it's
the opposite of an education it sounds
like you are now part of an institution
that's trying to change this uh so tell
us more about the university of austin
and texas is this physically in austin i
mean in your case you're you're
so uh so are you going to be flying
there on the regular
uh ayan hersey ali is the other uh
founding faculty member there are two
founding faculty members now it is in
austin and uh i've made that commitment
but it's only twice a year that i'll be
there and it's a very intensive time
where you teach and it's a it's starting
for a you know one year position and i'm
just looking at the board of advisors
and the board of directors and the
curriculum i've seen it's utterly
remarkable it's everything that i would
want for an education myself and for my
children how to engage ideas how to
think through what you what seemed to be
intractable problems how to do so
civilly how to listen to
you know sides of an argument that that
really don't get heard and you know the
other thing is
if if you put someone in in a in an
environment long enough where they never
hear the other side of the argument and
you tell them
either implicitly or explicitly oh the
people who believe this they're just bad
people that's when the threshold for
offense gets lower and lower and lower
and so people just become brittle and
they become incapable i know if you
heard the sanji gupta uh
uh conversation with joe rogan he just
when you're when your beliefs are never
questioned you just collapse you just
you just fold when someone
someone does so how do we create
students how do we create a more vibrant
and dynamic learning community you know
part of that is pedagogically it's in
the classroom it's the methods that we
use but the other part is we need to
create a culture that values changing
your mind civility and debate you know
when i was in the new atheist movement
and i would you know i went on tour for
months and months of time in australia
new zealand the bible belt everywhere
afterward i would go out with
not every night but often you know
months on end i would be on tour i would
go out with christians and we would
drink and we would just you know debate
the bible you would debate the existence
of god sometimes we'd hug each other
sometimes i sound like a philosophy
professor out in the world it sounds
like fun peter and that's what we should
do man that's the kind of institutions
that we need to create right now so it
i'm sick of bemoaning oh this is
happening on the college campus let's
build let's let's build a new thing i
think that that is in many ways like the
example we should try and set
uh i certainly believe in being more
difficult to offend um i personally am
quite difficult to offend which is
probably a good thing given my line of
work
but
but i'm also
a big fan of just trying to build the
better
uh version
where we can see what's going on around
us there are problems right and left
and some of us have the capacity to
perhaps try to
show that we can do better um certainly
i'm going to try and do that in terms of
political parties and our politics like
i think providing some kind of
multi-polar
version of our democracy is vital for
its survival
i think this duopoly is designed to fail
us and to fail
so that's one of my great projects but
i'm certainly very very excited about
what you're describing with the
university of austin
uh and who knows maybe i'll come down
maybe i'll guest lecture or something i
mean
when you guys are down there we yeah we
would absolutely love that you know you
mentioned the duopoly and and the
problems and i think at core we have to
remember that we are all americans amen
brother amen
and and we need we need to look at these
problems communally so instead of going
down down like oh he's asian or he's you
know jewish or whatever we need to go up
you know we're americans we're humans
etc you are a philosopher of the modern
age peter i'm so glad
that you've already found
the the new role the new project you
also have a substance if people want to
i do keep up with you and and your
findings and learnings is that right i
do and i've started a non-profit so i'll
i'll tell you one of the projects that
we're going to do
uh the first time i've announced that
it's months away
but we are
i'm gonna go a tour uh 15 universities
the first first time i've ever announced
it
and we're going to do a reverse q a
where i sit in the audience and i'm
going to ask people about their
experiences with woke ideology and
social justice
and we're partnering with student groups
and we're gonna um we're gonna really
listen to what students have to say and
what their education means to them and
if they feel that they're getting a good
education so uh we're doing that in fact
i'm going to la to shoot the uh
uh shoot the trailer for that
next week so i've got a lot of stuff
going on to the national progress
alliance is the name of it um yeah i
have a lot of projects i'm totally in my
sub stack is kind of cool you know i i
just started and it's fun so yeah like
that's your thing man like life is very
good for me right now it's just i just
i'm just very happy you know uh i i wake
up every day feeling great uh i don't
have people tormenting me you know both
places people want people want me to be
there it's a weird experience man it's
like you call somebody like oh we can't
wait for you to come it's the exact
opposite of what i got for portland
state every day like it was just
and so it's wonderful i just really
happy right now and i actually want to
want to um
thank you for what you've done and and
for your hard work and to let you know
that i will do everything i can to
support you and to have your back as we
move forward i think you have a unique
contribution to make to public discourse
and civic life well peter right back at
you i mean you're you're an intellectual
force in a time that genuinely needs it
i mean there aren't many people
doing your work right now and it's one
reason why i feel like a lot of this is
coming your way is because when people
look around for someone
to actually build a next generation
academic institution or help question
some of the orthodoxies you would be at
the top of a lot of people's list
congratulations again on on the new path
the sub stack
the university the tour uh people can
follow peter on social media as well i
do peter bogosian thank you so much i
enjoyed this conversation a great deal
a pleasure thank you andrew thank you
[Music]
you